welcome to this video about round 10 of
Tata Steel 2014 and round 10 this year's
the penultimate round and yeah it's also
the roundworm aronia may clinch this
tournament he is leading by one and a
half point and with another win he could
win this tournament with one round left
to go so let's start with the action
with the game van vainly against gelfand
yo here it is and let's see ya when
really playing the trump of scheme hmm
yeah I don't really recall him playing
that before I he probably has some games
with it but it's not a main main feature
of his opening repertoire and then
Gelfand answers with d5 yeah d5 is a
very solid response to the to the Trump
and can very much be recommended
especially to to classically inclined
players why term really yeah really is
asked what are you going to do now
because so are the Trump offski type
move would be to take on f6 give up the
bishop for the night and after that
Black has the interesting choice between
G takes with a more complicated game or
eat a except which is a very solid
choice leading to very decent playful
black because he's got quick quick
opening of the diagonals for the bishops
and has no development problems what
server and yeah well if why it does not
take like is probably try to play 94 so
this is something that white needs to
address him he played 92 and after c5
like attacking the center he took on c5
yeah they're already on very much
unknown territory have almost no games
available to to compare this to and as
mentioned in the earlier videos the
trend of getting away from explored
theory is really standing steadying it's
not something just to be observed in a
single game it's really an obvious trend
here we quickly see after Queen a5
blackest try to get the porn back and he
does so really quickly I'd have three
and 96 so this position is very similar
to the sloth defense but was colors
reversed white is basically playing ass
laughs here but he enjoys an extra tempo
which probably is some yeah enough to to
equalize but not more here really placed
now in the same spirit as in the Slav
takes here and place a form this is how
the convertible line with reversed
colors displayed as well II five reverse
colors bishop e6 Queenie seven and this
is just the same here and white develops
yeah this Bishop is six move it looks a
bit unnatural to play that but like has
a slight problem here what a shorty
plane if he wants to play the E porn at
some point yeah let's let's say you find
for example you have this problem this
is not playable
and for other reasons e 6 is not
playable I mean it's not as bad as the
other line but this does not look very
appealing is this kind of this kind of
structure yeah like has got so many weak
pawns don't want that it's a bit
difficult to develop the bishop on this
this diagonal so it probably was
thinking about bishop age six at some
point anyway and therefore it does not
really it's not really necessary to move
the eeprom so Bishop b6 and this Bishop
to h6 I think this is a decent
development scheme for black and a
general problem here in this position
for widest where to put the king it's um
especially with the bishop I ownage six
long castles hmm I don't know does not
look so attractive and well short
castles you're cancelling right into the
G file at the anti decided for short
castles and it's not the problem i mean
white is not suffering from King safety
issues 95 and he captured their mighty
form yeah i think this position should
be about equal I mean I personally
because I'm simply um yeah well well
known yeah the shop Bishop fan I'd like
to play with the two bishops especially
I mean who doesn't but I really have a
soft spot for that so I just prefer
black here um but it's not a position
where white should be in big trouble
he's got a good knight on d4 and
centralized pieces so it it's it's about
equal I guess
should be five Jack this thro the trade
trip to one where this is all very
logical yeah seaking to who the bishop
or maybe we located your even to be 6
yeah that's not not much going on but in
the next couple of moves I think that
went very is slowly allowing his
position to do to deteriorate play g3 ok
yeah like it wants to use the H porn as
a battering ram 92 but the deity care to
calculate the next line Bishop d to this
is a bit of a strange move because it's
a self pin and it's not a bad one not a
bad move but it's it's somewhat strange
to put the bishop into this help in and
there was no alternative however because
I after age 5 he had two had to
calculate that like has no other movie
he can't take you but a problem is that
now where's this Bishop going and it is
also h5 hanging and yeah after this
there are there more things coming up
that are problematic so this was a
really a mandatory move and of course
planned beforehand Queen to h4 we are
activating the Queen and Queen e5 yeah
we see that the bishop is somewhat more
powerful than the night but it's not not
serious reading
Yeah right here it starts to get a bit
strange i think you should probably just
just centralize and try to trade off
more pieces on the idea rookie form well
let's say rookie 4th so connected with a
very ambitious at DA wants to put
pressure on the h-bond which is in a way
understandable but it does not really
materialize to anything anything great
black just covers this from the side and
what is exactly happening here white
cannot increase the pressure on h 5 yard
look everyone is intending the next move
and i don't really like that the next
move like played Bishop to h6
recognizing no away from age 6
recognizing that the bishop is not doing
much there and he wants to relocate it
on c5 and I've the next move I'm really
amazed to that decision is played on my
very played f4 here which seems terribly
weakening to me especially considering
that this Bishop is on the way to c5 um
I understand that you wanted to to get
active play with little time of the
clock but they don't really like don't
really like that decision maybe it's not
it's not the decisive mistake probably
but what will get in trouble with the
weekend king queen needed to move of
course short term you gain something the
queen is not great on age six but it can
be activated by a h7 will see that
quickly bishop first to the diagonal
yeah this was all necessary um see
forever sorry I was a bit too quick see
forever is a mistake he should
gotten the Queen back into the game Oh
happily helping in defence but note that
this ruckus cut off we have four is
really a strange move here black black
hands multiple idea they cannot can even
try to get the Queen back into the
little play on d6 for example and also
getting it out of this this rooks x-ray
yeah like here on this one here why does
really weekend this position does not
feel very comfortable he played as mass
already shown because I was a bit too
quick c4 but after ruka d1 attorney gets
very tricky because some black starts
and immediate attack on the king let's
see five and black just retweeted and
the main problem we see we see now check
okay this is sorry it was too quick we
see now that luck is playing with this
idea and for example if he plays our
place as long let's say king here black
goes to g6 and threatens this IDM and
white is playing without the rook this
is the problem check
check Chuck yeah this is nothing that
white can can really survive black wins
quickly yeah the position after Ruby one
is already a not defensible anymore he
tried rook takes a try after the capture
played kingi too because the queen is
obviously attacked and at the same time
the rock is attacked but after Queen g6
so you see that like it's now invading
and some winning with the director King
side attack Chuck yeah the white penis
King is pushed forward Chuck yeah that
after this check probably influenced by
by a time Joel they they when does when
this fall how does this check rook g5 is
the only move after which chunk meat
Queen age eight is a nice checkmate we
see all whites pieces really miss placed
on this side of the board I really don't
think that f4 was such a such a
fortunate a DM i think around here and
also look to h4 probably in this tab
position why should just yeah play some
some solid stuff and maybe try to
simplify the position of it rock the one
night back to be three exchange a pair
of rooks something like that it's not
really leading to much but it should
keep the game yeah around level um and
this means that girl font has has won a
game he really has a rotten tournament
but at least he's on the scoreboard with
the wind now alright the next game let's
see what else do we have here we have
harikrishna against Wesley sell this I
will do rather quickly do you probably
have a sneaky suspicion suspicion here I
half the Berlin do we get the endgame
yes we get the endgame and yeah of this
kind of opening after Jack me trade it's
um one of those openings that are really
where I really understand the motivation
behind black black playing this opening
because it's a very solid and reliable
defense and sometimes you can even win
games with it if why this over-ambitious
or tries to do something that is not
really well thought out however as a
commentator this is just not a very nice
opening to look at because llam it all
depends on on very very um be on a level
of detail that is very hard to to master
if you um just analyze it briefly to to
present in the video there are some
games like that like this one i can i
can go through it rather quickly of
fairly logical black trying to secure
against the g4 move Bishop e7 ya 92 this
is some useful motif sometimes 94 as
possible sometimes not f4 serve as an
idea night h4 we have one pair of nights
traded Bishop f4 and Bishop back to e 72
yeah it's best to to relocate it on edge
for it it's not really doing much and
now after Knight g4 and g5 wide retweet
it Andrew age 6 yeah this all looks
completely normal it has been seen many
times this type of setup for black h5 g5
Luke h6 strengthening this blockade on
on the six square and white is
absolutely
at least in my book absolutely no idea
22 to strengthen the position black
simply plays Bishop d7 and yeah maybe
Ruby 8 always remember that you cannot
castle long here and Tess in the good
old days when much when into an chest
usually was analyzed on real board
wouldn't bored with pieces on it and
nobody was telling you why this is an
illegal move I can tell you that very
often you did analyze stuff that when it
was against the rules because you forgot
that okay well that was Catholic right
okay oh ok in this position white plate
e 6 and this is practically identical
with with conceding the draw at this
position black took here Bishop d7 those
two are traded and the black has no real
real possibility to keep the e-cigs
Bishop if you would be able to keep it
then like Eve nas's playing for
something a move like Bishop d7 it can
be you can be risky because it helped us
the coordination that he just played
rook c8 and after the trade here the
position is completely equal black has
no problems whatsoever and after check
some more trades chak chung player some
time around here agree to a draw after
perpetual here with the king of the rook
yeah this is sort of a nothing game at
some the type of game that is simply a
necessary part in the daily life of a
chess professional you sometimes just
need to play a solid games black
and the Berlin is a good choice for that
white has shown absolutely nothing here
it's very difficult for me not being an
expert on one year 14 to to point out
where white could have approved and the
ugly truth is that wide at the moment
has absolutely nothing against the
Berlin it's a still this problem that
has been a parent for a number of years
now that this end game is not really
netting anything and why does some
shifting is attention to what slower
moves like 2d three and and so on but
it's not really leading to much as well
all right so a rather uneventful draw
and let's go to the next game Geary
against coyoacán and this game you see
another Catalan and the Catalan nowadays
really has become White's main search
for an advantage against the Queens
gambit type of setups you see this
really more often than the then the
classical Queens gambit I'm not quite
sure why that is I mean the Queens
gambit of course is also very difficult
to to get anything as wide but the
Catalan recent is also quite solid for
black kayaking as we have seen earlier
the tournament you always place this
absolute most classical variation with
castles and then capturing and here
after those moves White has the
principal choice between taking on c4
day for curious usually playing a form
and he's doing that again in this in
this game we should be seven
yeah all this has been seen before even
in this tournament um a five also good
news like is intending to fix this week
before square and maybe use a night on
it here we go yeah Queen t3 is a
slightly strange move but the Queen
probably has to move away anyway and
he's doing that now night is coming to
be for all so anyway so it does not
really matter that you move the Queen
two times what the white is trying to
accomplish is a for after all and this
is what black tries to prevent his plane
95 and by challenging the c3 night black
is gaining some control over if I as he
voice just blundering it away and after
95 white played the bishop to d2 yeah
don't think white is necessarily afraid
of the double polar form but he just
wanted to I think keep a bit more pieces
on the board and try to improve the
position with rookie one for example and
then he follows is a possible idea black
just took on c3 slightly surprising but
after the capture and Bishop before we
see that black has very decent on piece
control over the center it's it's tricky
for white to to get any form or anything
substantial in the center right now of
course the queen size attacked so it
moved away and now queen d 5 we see that
this queen is even covering this crucial
c 4 square
and black can prepare on various poem
breaks you can prepare c5 at the right
moment or be five in the game will see
that after will be one and after the
trade black is playing would be aid
covering be seven but also intending to
play be five so we see that rather
quickly will be one
94 centralized the night after night f4
okay the Queen needs to go but still
it's not apparent how wide is going to
make any any headway here likes pieces
on okay it doesn't have any substantial
long-term weakness and after the trade
he went for this mentioned break with be
five this is a very straightforward way
to play try to get your hooks active and
after this capture basically forced I
guess it's hard hard not to capture and
after the capture black has this a pond
and what needs to be a bit a bit
commercials here not it's not in trouble
but if he ignores this um passo it can
it can be tricky see form give Ria's
immediately immediately tried to kill
the game off and in fact this happens
black takes it's not really am have any
big alternative to that after the trade
cm we have come to completely
symmetrical position that after Queen
this yes twinkie agent some more moves
it does not really matter much after
history exactly here they agreed to it
wrong yeah normal not a very exciting
game but probably um yeah and in some
way I understand all the tournament
already has has been rather rather long
and both players don't really have a
realistic chance anymore to fight for
first place I roni and it's not going to
lose this last two games it's very
unlikely so this game was played with
with caution in
I guess and caution or let's say boredom
taken away we we got so not very
spectacular chassis m let's go to the
next game kawana against my dish yeah
koala is some having a social tournament
not not terrible not great one night is
having probably the worst event ever at
least in recent years what what I am
could could remember his dad died his
last place and only has managed a couple
of drawers so let's see what happens
here Alana's playing Knight f3 g3 has
done that recently quite often and
following the already mentioned trend of
going away from from main line openings
and again in this game we quickly reach
another theoretical position a position
that is completely unexplored g6 and ce4
yeah this is a very understandable move
white needs to fight for the center at
one point you cannot avoid this all the
time with castles and slow moves at one
point c4 is necessary to attack the
center yeah of course you can play stuff
like d 392 Kings Indian attack style but
it does not really need to to an
advantage while see form is a move that
really a does fight for something for
example if black now supports the center
white as B 3 and B should be two leading
to a slightly more comfortable game for
white it's not much but it's slightly
more comfortable for white and we have
black plays move like deform bit of
dishes this be four interesting play
there should be two will pressurize the
default
so what should like do wear that's also
Bishop g7 of course and after that we
get to an English type of position that
can also transpose to a green felt with
B form I would deform not be fond d form
of course so very interesting
transposition and leading to two
fighting fighting games a black however
played something entirely different he
took on c4 which is not very common but
of course why not you do that all the
time in the Greenfeld and this time it's
also interesting if white goes for check
it's interesting like black has more
than one possible reply even that one is
some quite quite decent Bishop g7 I
guess so and Knight b6 knight c6 to come
so one possibility but knowledge played
it differently play tonight a3 which is
not bad at all of course at intends to
get the night edge kawana ok why nice
white karana played night a 3-2 to get
the pawn back and he did this did this
quickly c5 getting some control over d 4
and this is answered interestingly
enough by Ned f-35 even before castling
and with this move we we are on unknown
territory this never has been played
before and some slightly unconventional
move the okay the most normal would be a
castle in here obviously but after that
black plays Knight c6 and get some
influence over the e5 square and that
was white going to make any progress
here you cannot play d4 bloggers
covering that reliably and so on if you
go nitey 5 and this type position you
only exchange pieces and this generally
helps the defender
peruana certainly wanted to win this
game playing against it completely out
of shape knowledge so he wanted to I
guess get a more complicated position
and went for knight ft 5 this is also
hampering blacks development a bit as
the natural move knight c6 is not
working and yeah well if you need to do
something like 97 you're blocking your
bishop on CA it so it's an interesting
try to post some problems for black I
think knowledge is playing and playing
it fine it just castles and goes for
night d 5 this is increasing some
pressure on you five and of course this
is not a very stable peace yeah it's not
supported by porn and rather quickly we
see that in six was necessary make the
night more secure on d5 and yeah this is
what I was trying to say attacking the
knight and TM yeah white has no choice
he needs to support it and place a f4
yeah very interesting position and it
completely completely new you hardly
ever see a combination of c-4 traded
against the deep own and then f4 in the
English opening I mean I have played
this types of positions form for ages
and you really never see in the 8th porn
used but it's of course interesting it
keeps lots of control over a five and I
think for a long while White has a
completely fine position 97 and Bishop
t2 yeah if black now takes on e5 whiter
of course will recapture and while black
cannot not win a pony can he can take
care but right after that it's it's very
risky considering that if form
will dislodge the night and then bishops
III will come on the long diagonal this
is a position where even the computer
gives white substantial compensation and
it's certainly not seeing a direct
meeting attack this is too risky and
knowledge didn't go for that he's not
the kind of player 2 to care to not
accept the challenge he usually does
that but he had seemed too risky even
for him he played b6 completing his
development and now wyd retreat it I
cannot keep it down on the longer the
long run now efore gaining space in the
center a black going to before they're
going for the most active square not
retreating um yeah what happens if white
captures the pawn is this good yeah the
problem is that at the end after most
like 95 this is a week and both bishops
now are excellently placed white will
learn beyond the defense of really
quickly and like for example look
everyone rook 88 attacking here and this
already is it's a problem how to defend
that if white plays a move like we need
3 to 2 comedy 3 there's still the
capture because this is such an unstable
piece black has enormous pressure this
is why why didn't take you just played
Bishop d3 which is just stronger you
want to challenge the strong g7 Bishop
like play b5 attacking the night and we
have the trade check and reach this
position yeah it's a a very unclear
complicated position now
and 26 yeah let's have a look at that
yeah white has some weaknesses d 493 is
weak blacks camp there c5 as a weakness
it probably should should be around
equal but it's not the equal type of
game that that deletes to nothing and so
it's dynamically equal lots of things
happening plane I'd be three trying to
attack the weakness and this is answered
very directly by knowledge is playing
rook c8 preparing to advance with C form
and this is what what later happens the
Roxy 197 v5m Queen away check the street
and King edge 1 it cannot stay in this
long diagonal all the time after all
that knowledge plays 95 and now see for
ya this phase of the game is really
complicated you could um get analyze it
much much deeper if you want it's
probably about equal there's no reason
why am one side should should have an
advantage at first you might think that
after something like this the capture
here that black has the worst pawn
structure this is true those three
points are young isolated but pawn
structure is just one feature of the
position if you look at this after night
here 95 we see that black has some
assets as well he's got a good Bishop on
b7 and first oops first of all those two
nights are very strong especially
considering that 93 is going to be the
next improvement in blacks position
koala now went for whoopsie to
Roxy form is unfortunately answered by
94 and this leads to big trouble
something like that oops with this one
of course screwed up my notes here just
just a frog of course I was just taking
him why not the frog and the focus what
I have in my in my text yeah this is why
white cannot really take on c4 in the
game we played Roxy too so covering the
spawn and 93 yeah this is a very tricky
position to play especially with little
time on the clock koala played be three
this is quite an obvious move attacking
the strong c4 porn but it's also
somewhat risky move because of the reply
that knowledge is playing and displaying
the sharpest smooth night to be too
which looks with the Brit a bit wacky at
first what is like doing only too well
the simple ideas of course that the
capture is answered by the fork this is
rather easy to see but the question that
you need to ask yourself what is this
night doing on be too isn't it just
stranded it's not attacking anything
well it's that's true but still the main
point is that this night move was a
paving the way for the Seaport after 95
like one c3 and that is a strong porn on
c3 that white needs to yeah be be
cautious about okay move the Queen away
it was attacked and now look to the
eighth yeah and now I guess with limited
time I don't trust the
clocks here that they used by a Cecily
seem weird sometimes especially if you
look at them and the flow of the game
sometimes one side gains a couple of
minutes so there must have been some
relay issues it's very difficult to
judge how much time they was left but we
are more 32 I guess maybe come on I
didn't have so much time left yeah why
am I talking about the time so much
because now why does some basically
blundering the game away with little one
mover and not that it is completely easy
after that but it's just one move that
spoils the entire position for white if
he plays um yeah good move here it's
probably just about equal the computer
suggests the somewhat strange looking
north quincy one the idea is probably to
get out of the air farm after that their
alliance that in fact lead to to an
equal position 11 being night takes a
form very aggressive and move um that
however leads to trades white takes like
techsoup's here check down or queen
takes also interesting yeah now white
can go for counter play with the tag and
to retreat to try to get the sea porn
yeah this type of position is is very
complicated and unclear but is it is
what white should have tried Queen g1 is
not a very to ative news though um
however what he did I mean rookie one is
the movie that he played that really
instantly loses that much that much is
clear and it did losses due 2nite XF
form the same move that we saw earlier
White has no big choice he needs to take
it
after that the rook takes on deform and
it's um yeah not not difficult to see
her and that that white is in huge
trouble here for is just terminally week
and it's not even white is not able to
defend against that and then addition
there's also the wii king of course he
played the rook takes III and this was
answered by 91 always funny to see night
journey all the way to the opponent's
back rank don't have that too often with
many pieces on the board yeah and the
night is also of course nearing the
always critical f 2 square check yeah
rooks e7 check kind of a shocking move
it's a protected square on c7 and they
were here black actually he could have
taken it could have taken it's not not
the best move but i could have taken
after this um black is infected and in
trouble yeah how does see how does he
care with that I guess he doesn't yeah
well it's not so important because after
Luke c7 check night it just played king
j it and ignored all that and of course
before white can can take anywhere he
needs to take care of the queen ant is
attacked and of course you you cannot
take this check is made into yeah he
played played the Queen to see to and
after that black just just took on f4
and yeah what has fights supposed to do
now it's really a really an ugly
position if if he takes here for example
check we again have a quick checkmate
quick checkmate
yeah what he did is he played them
kawana played rook takes me seven and
this now leads to an very nice finish
check now I have to check now only move
sat night h3 double check so only kick
h1 necessary the artist is completely
false chalo Jack King edge one necessary
yeah now note that the typical smothers
late is still covered by the Queen but
the motif is still used if you want you
can look at this position and trade it
has a little puzzle like to move when I
only give you a couple of seconds
because it's not so difficult okay going
going to show it the move that was
played in the game is a shot look
everyone check and now wyd resides due
to a coming mate rook takes a rook take
jack you should take sand then check
Nate Queen g1 mate very nice checkmate
and wow it's a win for knowledge finally
after having suffered in so many games
c11 a nice game and a nice finish at the
anterior against very strong from Jana
kawana yeah I guess carry on karana just
lost the thread here in the complicated
position with little time on the clock
around here rookie one was just just
giving it away I guess there was some
sometime issue involved because night x
therefore it's not a very difficult
reply and should be easily spotted by
karana alright so next game what do we
have here we have also report against
Nakamura and while judging by the
performance so far
the tournament you're always on we are
almost guaranteed to have a somewhat
strange or complicated game coming up
because report is playing those really
am yes sometimes even wacky openings
when I cameras not exactly a saint in
this part of the game it as well as I
mean what I'm trying to say is he also
likes to play creative chess if possible
so let's see what we get 93 c 5 b 3 yeah
okay well we are already away from
mainstream theory three yeah the 66
needs need some some explanation this
sir it looks like a bit of a bit of a
yeah bit of a little move yeah why only
d6 of course black has other setups but
this system has a very young
positionally well-founded idea black
wants to play e5 and this type of setup
let's say I'm he plays you three here if
I have check we can put this if white
now it's not playing we should be five
just playing let's say normal moves yeah
well here that's even if or sending the
night back which is another point of
course in general what like is trying to
do is to to build up a wall in the
center that also kills this Bishop it's
only biting on granite from be too and
therefore d6 is a very a very decent and
strategically well-founded IDM check
Bishop b5 has played trying to speed up
development and if possible also to
build up a pin after 96 played in the
game this is of course opinion yeah note
that white would really like to play d4
him attacking the center but check
there's an obvious drawback so t4 is not
particularly well timed
he played 93 bit of a strange move
because while after Bishop b2 and this
world will be played later the night is
yeah not very very effectively placed on
t3 it just blocks the long diagonal
however it has a very concrete idea he
wants to I guess protect this bishop to
get deform back into the mix this is
what nakamura played he needs to get get
ahead with development and the report
answer deform as i already mentioned
this was the the idea behind 93 yeah
it's already very concrete IAM white is
just threatening to take on e5 and win
the whole empordà 5 porn yeah black
break will ya only has one replied at
seven getting forced year black plays a
form the most logical attacking the
night and two came the night does not
really have such a great square at the
moment um in addition why it has a much
more attractive option and this is what
reporters playing is playing d5 using
this pin and forcing basically um to
play a 6 and now we retreated to f1 yeah
all very curious but what else couldn't
go to go to e 2 s now like it's
attacking the two bishop and whiter
loses a piece you needed to go all the
way back but this is certainly a what he
intended because after 97 and now 92 we
have a very interesting struggle in the
center well those two pawns
a bit exposed d5 is not really well
supported and the same applies also for
a form this pawn also has only
insufficient cover there's no natural
yeah poor move to to cover it like f5 or
like z4 so it's a piece struggle um for
the center Bishop f5 covering the pawn
no be should be too yeah note that if
black takes on d5 we could have done
that theoretically speaking that this
kind of um trade in the center probably
tends to favor wines because he is a bit
quicker in development with Bishop b2
also putting pressure on the g7 born so
it's a slightly better for wide oh this
is why I'm Bishop f5 was played be sure
to be too and now nakamura played b5 an
ambitious move again you could could
check the trade but here why it has the
interesting reply night XD for using
this somewhat liar of somewhat
unreliable center black cat after taking
here is worse after Queen d5 or if you
take here this is also not great so
taking on d5 is not really good b5 is
just stronger this some gains space on
the queenside and it tends to play
before at the right moment to really
drive the c3 night away and then when
the d5 pawn yeah white responded with
age three
this is 22 ideas covering g4 and
preparing g4 of course g4 Bishop g2 to
put more pressure on the fourth wall
it's very logical move in fact yeah h5
just preventing that and here right now
initiated a very very sharp sequence and
then three debatable this is a good good
decision especially considering that he
had a good alternative at first we need
to look at this move this is what he
played and nakamura answered with 98
here this position white plate plate as
mentioned a very sharp move and this
leads to interesting plane but I think
here the computer has an interesting
suggestion and I actually think that
this is a good to good move computer
wants to play a 3 which at first look
down yeah somewhat strange to me to be
honest that wider weakens his dark
squares like that but such an abstract
train of thought is some is sometimes um
yeah really am really bad in modern
chest you just need to calculate
completely if this has got some concrete
benefit or not and in fact that it's
quite quite clear that it will will help
widen activating his position if black
takes to start with the easy the easy
line Queen takes just gains an important
temple white is better developed yet and
while black cannot afford to take after
you for this shabbos almost wrapped so
you will have sorry yeah he will just
retreat here
and after that yeah white has more than
one interesting move but Bishop b3 is
the easiest yeah let's say after the
straight white is ready to use the the
new ganden the new square the center
that he gained 294 also he has lots of
pressure on the diagonal and to come on
the FR with luca have one or short
castle and a good position of a wide I
think that after every black should
defend differently one possible move
this Queenie 7 covering you form but
yeah white if everything else fails can
go for this the straights and now play
another take Queen d2 we see that the
weakening of the dark squares is
completely irrelevant because the
activity counts much more this Bishop is
just very strong and why it may castle
and then get more pieces into play I
think this is a very comfortable
position for four wide yeah a free maybe
was good for white it looks it looks
very attempting if you study it a bit
more detailed yeah a force what he
played and this initiates after be 492
and the very weird sequence black now
takes this is what white of this Liam
wanted to provoke and now we played an
IG 3 attacking this Bishop and then
tending to get the porn back and at the
end while white will have a very nice
diagonal however the cameras next move
was yeah very very surprising and maybe
a shocking here just sacrificed only
three and this is really remarkable and
however if you look at it at the
position that rises after
it you rather quickly see that black
definitely has some compensation but
it's still another matter to really play
the move yeah if white no takes which he
didn't do but if white takes the idea of
all this is Queen age form know the pin
King f2 and now d5 and we see that black
has for the P sacrifice yeah he's got
he's got two pawns very strong central
pawns and he's got this pin working for
him yeah we probably get to a position
like that but should be to Larry this is
very logical I think because white needs
to protect the g3 night and allow the
King to use so we should be to push up d
690 df1 and 97 getting the night back
into the game and this is a position
that it is that is immensely difficult
to play for white you will never ever
probably get really good coordination
and this in this game and black just has
the much much easier play here being the
act of the active site and the tackle um
still it was what white needed to do I
think after 93 he didn't capture
amazingly enough and played Queenie to
that I mean the situation after Queenie
2 is also super complicated so I
understand that maybe he had some some
idea that was not really working out but
it just seems that F takes III was was
the better move Jack like not took on
see you see one was check quite an
obvious move kinky one and now he
retreated
the the bishop yeah it was hanging and
this is also the reason why capturing
here after night eggs at five wasn't
really advisable it's just much better
to retreat the bishop and rely on this
diagonal with this discover checks yeah
here white also could have taken on see
to this is a move that needs to be
checked and the point is one point is
that is really like being a check it's
not helping much white just retreat and
yeah well this is Pawn will fall it's
just the useless check what black will
do is play d5 and yellow just attack at
this position he's got three pawns for
for peace and well this is not a very
good king and it will not find a safe
place quickly that's that's for sure
very a very complicated position you can
even consider p sacrifices only for him
yeah once I'm very very very complicated
yeah he played something else he took on
e4 which is interesting I mean a move
that threatens the checkmate hit one
move is always something that you you
need to you need to need to check um
yeah like replied with Queenie seven I
guess good a good defense the computer
however does not like it it it
recommends ninety seven witches again a
very unhuman move to play me getting the
knight to e7 clogging up your
development even further very tough form
for a human to play that it's also of
course based on the fact that any
capture on c2 is answered by g5 so for
example Quincy to
there's d5 and yeah like we'll get a
piece but note that at the moment if you
you count it black as a piece down he
first needs to get it back to even be a
to be materially hat IAM and very very
murky position however it's probably
okay for black he played however queries
happen which is not bad but the other
movies maybe at least in mathematical
terms better now queen III was played
and this in fact seems to be the
decisive mistake by white if he captures
on c2 with the king that's d5 coming and
this is also the case for quincy too so
this is probably what you should have
done and in fact this is not so
difficult to calculate and not not quite
sure what you overlooked when he played
Guinan 3 here this is something that
white can quite easily SSD five is
necessary like let's try to get get the
piece back in utilizing the pin and this
can be answered by Bishop d3 after which
the capture Bishop cakes is almost
forced and it turns out that after this
now probably black trades because the
rook is also hanging takes Knight eggs
we see that we get to an end yeah
endgame type of position where white
will quickly get in rookie one and he
has a very strong knight on e4 in a very
strong bishop and this is perfectly
okay okay for what he is not even worse
yeah just having very good compensation
for the porn and this is probably the
the easiest way to play leading to a
rather yeah a manageable position where
you can really have play in place of
some normal moves um he played Queen f3
however as mentioned and this simply
does not work but it's not not trivial
at oh of course yeah he took the look
and what now Bishop c4 this was reports
at the end he can also try some other
things but it's not really working this
is the problem let's say this check this
is a possibility takes takes him yeah
and fortunately there's this move oops
check yeah this crossfire you nobody
wants to be in yeah Knight f6 is not a
move that that is working you can try
that liquidating this but again Black
has defensive resources the best one
here probably being t5 to answer push-up
f6 with the amazing boogie form and it's
a it's just not enough it just not
enough Queen Ephraim yeah Pusha page six
black has a very good give defensive
resources yeah in the game Bishop c4 was
played he's obviously hoping for an
attack along the e-file night to be six
check and Knight f6 check this was the
idea all along like takes and Bishop
takes a white now is really lots of
material
down black black still has all his
pieces two bishops two nights troops and
so on while white already has sacrificed
a night and rook but okay he's got some
attack that's clear Queen moved check I
groupie one check yeah like some keys
but not comfortable but after King b7
it's it's just the problem is it might
not look comfortable but if you if you
have one so much material you don't if
you don't really mind and the
all-important squares are still covered
like his happen rookies happiness not
possible yeah white at the end he
decided to grab maturity took the night
in only one which you may want now
nakamura plays Quincy six this is just a
very strong and good decision he just
does not care about this bishop
attacking the rook he just gives it back
because now why does almost forced to to
take on c6 there is no real alternative
where you going to go with the Queen
chattox takes on a jade and at first you
might think okay why are not ttttt for
all the material back the thing is with
this bad King position you always need
to be to be very aware of technical
tricks and with Queens off and we can
put more moves on the board the plate
age for driving the night away and then
took here you look at this position if
you see this position before I'd in your
calculation you just go for that it's
it's completely winning black cam enjoys
an extra porn is the enjoys the B porn
and the two bishops and this is such an
easy win that you should just go for
that on some other position where you
are look up but where the other side has
definite play you simply should avoid so
this is a very good decision when I come
around he's quickly rewarded and the Sun
in this game check so Chapel of more
booze um yea hear yea even report I'm
resigned the game young for example
engage form who should be seven is sort
of double attacking him and here in
trapping the rook yeah and it wasn't
really if necessary to trap even more
material s black is winning anyway with
the two the two passes so a very murky
complicated game that really am yeah
should it could be a analyze much deeper
but ok my time is is limited in this
video is already getting so long I can't
believe it ok so we only have one game
left and I save them the most important
game for the tournament for last this is
Dominguez against Aronian let's go to
that the opening is no surprise in this
game Dominguez is relieved she playing
is he always playing e4 there are almost
all the time I cannot really recall him
not playing your form but yeah maybe
once in a while deviates but it was some
if you would frost me to guess in
opening I would've guessed exactly this
position as domingues is playing the way
all the time aronian is playing a five
all the time so we get this Spanish
model mainline royal castles 93-86 a
three we have seen this before the
number of times even in this tournament
domingues has played this before 9 a-5
you should pay to and Bishop e6 yeah
this is all very standard in the in the
way black uses Knight a5 gaining a move
on the b3 bishop and you freeze the c
pointer moves which happens now um yeah
I always have a slight problem when when
doing this this kind of um this time
this type of structure because I'm many
45 players black and a half those
positions all the time is black and well
of course I do know why its ideas but
still I always tend to feel that if like
a manages to get in c5 and have such a
nice control over the center you
shouldn't be a really worse and I don't
really think like black is worse here
this d 393 a three inch and Rainier put
so much pressure on black um however the
next move by Dominguez I don't really
like at some it's probably new moves i
only found one other game in this
position and the approach chosen in this
in this other game i like much more than
the strong russian grandma's alexander
mati left monster to 670 player could
have easily played in them and why key
as well he recently played Bishop takes
f6 the ship takes f6 and 95 this is or
at least not better but this is much
more to my taste I like to play with
them yeah with those some strong points
in the center and not weakening why my
queen sodium it's not it's nothing
special here but I I would prefer that I
I think that before yeah weakening
yourself more than
then then gaining much yeah black just
retreated and after 95 he took on d5 and
put the knight on d4 and I think really
before it just weakened the queenside
it's not having so many many positive
effects um not saying that white is in
terrible shape but I really don't like
the idea okay white took on c5 check
black captures on f3 and black of course
need to get the palm back and now we see
that this type of structural
transformation has changed life for the
a2 bishop a lot he's looking at this d5
pawn and besides through that it's not
doing much and we see that this is a
constant worry now here play rook e1 and
aronian plate 97 yeah he wants to
blockade the deep one with Bishop b6 and
he prepares that with night d 7 they are
the trade is really am nothing much
black can even go to d6 and note that
this always keeps the a2 bishop out of
the game this is what point were white
played keeping the bishops and now
Bishop to b6 blocking the pawn and
intending f5 and we see evil f5 yeah in
this position I am I personally already
would prefer black him and it looks like
those pawns and cover lots of useful
squares the computer is not so
enthusiastic about blacks position it at
best gives gives black equality here but
I don't I don't really see what White's
play em
consists of what is exactly black white
doing here you cannot really attack the
center and you're not getting anywhere
with peace play you play the Bishop b3
now also covering a for this was really
a threat but it just gives a bit more
harmony to to White's position and now
our own young played the very
straightforward movie form yeah and
around here it it is the point where you
really need to look for improvements for
wide while I was some stating that i am
I already like blacks position this
still means that black is not better but
in a couple of most black will be better
and it's difficult to to really find the
exact spot where where this happened
whether where the Vantage definitely
shifted to black and I think the next
move is a bit accommodating you took on
your form maybe it's better to to move
the Queen to I don't know where I'm to a
Sri maybe and not really take take
yourself on your form I mean black can
play in a way that you just let the poor
stay on you for and sort of provoke
white into taking but this is a bit
different now than than the game let me
show what happened in the game after the
capture you played see for this was the
ideal asleep attacking the bishop needed
to retweet and then queen edge form and
the whole point was that yeah this is a
threat this is a threat Queen takes
don't point of all this this is that
this bishop on a tune is shut out of the
game by the pawns b5 and see form and
well after Queen edge form plate
if I've tossing upon the problem is one
problem is if you play g3 there's also
95 coming and yeah what now this for
example is just terrible the night is
immediately using the weakened light
squares note that this Bishop is just
out of this world bad and this is
already already gone this is also why
white tossed in a pond I think this is a
good decision took with the bishop and
now g3 yeah now the queen is attacked
obviously and that went to g4 offering a
queen trade black certainly does not
mind the Queen trade here because he
already has a pretty good idea how it
tries how is always trying to to get
something in the game and this is due to
three against two majority him the
queenside pawns are blacks sotm white
traded and now played c3 and I think c3
is a definite mistake yeah I'm pretty
sure that this is the wrong one he
probably shouldn't have played this pawn
move it on and try something else like
rook do you wanna just try to coordinate
a bit more c3 is just bad due to a
concrete IDM and here we have very
complicated position again black can
play something like ruka three you know
getting this idea into the game Bishop
deform yeah it's still a very
complicated game that this is hard
assess really i think that chances
should be should be around not equally m
the computer is is giving it as equal
but it's not not the type of draw is
equal it's the big fight ad C 3 has a
big drawback though what dooming has
play and the drawback is that this is
happening and this was very difficult to
to avoid um now the bpong really becomes
a formidable force played rookie three
covering the porn now black after ook
dat Bishop f5 h5 was able to push that
he waited until this move this rook
moved away from he won so that b3 was
was well timed and this is already
already gone I think I don't think white
can defend that just like this the whole
queen size s is falling apart you played
Bishop see one push-up reform jack yeah
we have the trade and now 95 85 ng6 this
is a position that I definitely wanted
to show it's very very funny to see that
the six bishop is is dominated here
cannot go anywhere it simply has no
square can go to f7 but after the trade
king g7 that his son was trapped white
after rookie one and king a king g7
decided to push the deep on again he
didn't really have any any great idea
because the bishop on his six was
completely useless yanti Aronian went
for the simple approach he just took
material off
and prepared Luke f king f7 here this is
the preparation for king of seven
gaining the porn after dat 8d rook d3 he
attacked the CFE porn and this is not
defensible anymore a rookie three you
can play to defend the porn but well
this is just just far too much so again
a win for the minyan number one and
world's number two Aronian and with this
when he has clinched them tournament
victory there is his fourth win in the
Tata Steel tournament or the Vikings a
tournament because as Tata Steel has
changed names a number of times I think
he already he also had won it whenever
stood the chorus tournament area and
excellent performance by Aronian with
another fine witness black and with that
when he also has some leveled his his
life yellow rating to a new record high
of 2831 or something about 2830 this
also means that he's almost 50 points
ahead of the world number 3 and at the
moment but quite sure who the world
number three is Nakamura is not he he
lost to too many points in the stone
maybe it's even Kramnik the other
players didn't didn't do much um yeah
but Aronian has a really nice rating
difference build up now with this fine
performance cm in white yeah if we look
ahead okay there's still another round
played tomorrow but if we look ahead in
the tournament calendar will see that
the next elite tournament is just around
the corner the zurich chess challenge
also ronnian will play there also cards
and after that we have the candidates
around the corner early early march well
of course it counts
all those victories and strong
tournaments are nice for Ronan but he
definitely wants a world championship
match and would be a great match to see
him again scars all right i hope you
enjoyed this coverage i'll be back of
course tomorrow with the final round
action of the Tata Steel tournament
thanks for watching I'll be back
tomorrow